In this tutorial, we'll be
talking about how to run the
Java sample code.
To run the YouTube Java samples,
we'll need the
following--
Java 1.6, Apache Maven,
access to a command
line, and a text editor.
In a future segment, we'll walk
through the process of
running and modifying the Java
samples from an IDE such as
Eclipse or IntelliJ IDE.
For this tutorial, we'll be
running our samples from the
command line.
The first thing I want to do is
download the code from this
site on Project Hosting.
Browse to code.google.com/
p/youtube-api-samples.
You can also search for
"YouTube-api-samples" in your
favorite search engine
and click on
the link to the samples.
Click on the download link.
This will take us to the page
where you can download the
code samples.
We'll save the zip file
to our local disk.
Now let's go ahead and
unzip the zip file.
It's now in my Downloads
directory.
I'm going to go ahead and browse
to this directory from
the command line.
I'm opening this up in Sublime
Text, but you can use any text
editor that works for you.
We're running two samples.
The first sample we're
going to run is going
to be a search sample.
Browse to search.java
in the YouTube
command line search project.
This is under Samples, Java,
YouTube Command Line Search,
Source, Main, Java,
Com, Google, API,
Services, Sample, YouTube.
There's a whole hierarchy.
I won't get too much into it.
But you want to go all the
way to the bottom of
the directory structure.
Open up the source code.
We'll see that this file
makes a reference to
YouTube.properties file, which
it loads when it starts up in
the main function.
It then uses the developer
key from this file.
This allows the specify
developer key and change
developer key without having
to recompile the project.
Let's browse to this
YouTube.properties file.
Right now this has
a placeholder.
We'll need to copy the API key
into this file so we can run
the sample.
Let's browse back to
the API console.
If you've seen the first
tutorial about how to do this,
it will explain how to
create this API key.
Let's copy the API key.
Switching back, let's
go ahead and paste
over the place holder.
Now let's save the file.
We're now ready to compile
and run this code.
Open up the command
line again.
We're browsing the samples,
and we're
drilling all the way down.
We're now going to use the Maven
tool to build and run
this product.
Type in mvn to make sure you
have a working Maven
installation.
Now let's go ahead and
type mvn compile.
This will download any
dependencies and compile the
project for us.
We're looking for "build
success." This ran fairly
quickly on my machine, but
that's because I've run this
sample before.
Your very first time running
Maven Compile on any Google
API project will take a little
bit longer, because you need
to download the dependencies.
Now let's go ahead
and run the code.
To do this, type
mvn exec:java.
This will run the
correct project.
In this case, I'm going to
search for the term "dogs
dancing."
This will output a list
of videos that
match my search query.
I can now go back to search.java
and make changes
to learn about the API,
recompile using mvn compile,
and run using mvn exec:java.
The second sample we're going
to run is going to
authenticate and authorize
using OAuth 2.0.
We're going to run the
My Upload Sample.
Browse to the My Upload Sample
in your YouTube Samples
directory, and drill all
the way down, as we
did in the last step.
This one loads a different
configuration file called
client_secrets.json.
Let's go ahead and
open that file.
This makes use of client ID and
the client secret, which
we created in a previous
tutorial.
Let's go back to the API console
and copy and paste
these values.
We're no longer using
simple API access.
We want to use the client
ID and client secret.
Let's go ahead copy the client
ID, paste it into the value
for client ID in our
client_secrets.json.
Let's go ahead and copy
client secret.
We'll paste that in as well.
Let's go ahead and
save this file.
There's one more thing
we need to do.
When we run the sample,
it's going to
create a local server.
This is going to accept
the browser redirect.
I'll show you what this
means in a second.
For now, what we need to do is
go back to the API console,
and we need to set a redirect
URI for our client ID.
I already have this set up, but
you probably won't have
this, so you want to go ahead
and click Edit Settings and
add the value
http://localhost:8080/Callback.
Click update.
I'll show you what this means.
Browse to your command
line again.
Let's enter the My Uploads
directory.
Again, we compile using mvn
compile, Maven Compile.
It goes ahead and installs all
of our dependencies, and it
compiles the code.
Now let's run the code
with mvn exec:java.
Notice that it automatically
redirects my browser and it
closes it if you authorized
in the past.
If I hadn't authorized this in
the past, I would be presented
with a screen that says, this
application is requesting
permission to your
YouTube account.
You'll need to click Allow
Access for this to work.
Going back to the command line,
we'll see that this has
appropriately listed out the
videos that I've uploaded.
Going back to our text editor,
we can see that we can make
changes to myuploads.java, save
them, and, using Maven
Compile and mvn exec:java, learn
about the API and OAuth
2.0 authorized API calls.
That concludes this tutorial.
In a future segment, we'll talk
about how to integrate
with an IDE.